[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and a
certain video has been floating around
the internet recently it's called phone
blocks has more than 8 million views
more than 150 000 thumbs up and more
than 20 000 plus ones so let's go ahead
and break this down this is phone blocks
explained so phone blocks is the idea of
a totally modular smartphone it stems
from the notion that when people get
done with a smartphone and it's time to
replace it it's usually because of a
single reason maybe it's getting too
slow or they don't like the camera
anymore or maybe the screen broke and
they throw out the entire phone even
though the rest of the phone is probably
still perfectly fine and that creates a
lot of unnecessary waste so the phone
blocks concept is a sort of a central
motherboard or base that all the rest of
the parts will plug into in a sort of a
block shape and they all fit together
kind of like legos this way if someone
decides they don't like part of the
smartphone or if they want to change a
certain thing they don't have to throw
out the whole phone just like legos they
can actually just remove and reattach
and rearrange the parts of the
smartphone to create exactly what they
want makes perfect sense what's
different about this video is it's half
tech concept half social media campaign
essentially what they're doing is asking
everyone to build up the hype on social
media about phone blocks until a certain
day
when everyone will talk about this
concept kind of reminds me of the kony
2012 campaign from a while back but
either way it doesn't matter what it
reminds you of at the end of the day
it's working and it's getting a lot of
people's attention and this is the first
time i've seen this dream phone concept
actually catch the eye of a lot of
regular people like this as part of the
campaign they're asking for you to sign
up for a service called thunderclap
where once you sign in on a social
network everyone who signs up will have
their account automatically send out the
exact same tweet or facebook post or
google plus post at the exact same time
on the same day so far more than 300 000
people have signed it so that's going to
be quite a trending topic on that day so
there are a couple of logistic things to
consider about phone blocks number one
who's going to make the blocks in the
concept video they showed that they
wanted to get the attention of and work
with very big companies big
manufacturers already and get them to
make phone blocks so that people can put
parts from trusted manufacturers in
their custom phones so speaker choices
from bose harman kardon bang olufsen
beats by dre whatever camera choices
from sony samsung maybe canon processor
choices from intel qualcomm ti etc and
that would make sense but there isn't
really any incentive right now for these
companies to buy into it they're all
invested right now in making their own
products because that's where the
margins are and speaking of margins
number two this is a very expensive
concept building a phone the equivalent
of the samsung galaxy s4 on paper for
example out of phone blocks would end up
costing probably twice as much and it
would be a much much larger device this
is because smartphone makers right now
have something called the supply chain
where they're just cranking hundreds of
thousands even millions of identical
smartphones off the assembly line the
devices they're making have a very
specific extremely compact design if
you've ever taken apart a phone or even
just looked inside the back of one
you'll see these parts are tied together
really tight woven in between each other
and crammed in there to keep the phone
thin and light and efficient and also
pretty with this final smartphone design
the more smartphones they crank out the
more streamlined the process gets and
the lower the costs get the more money
they save but building individual
smartphone parts like the gyroscope and
all the sensors and the camera parts and
the battery without weaving them
together that's going to be a very big
and very expensive smartphone so here's
the thing about phone blocks while the
idea itself is really cool and very
positive and the motives are all great
the logistics behind it are damn near
impossible to pull off right now
but that's not the point that's not what
this is about like we said earlier phone
blocks is really just the idea of a
completely modular smartphone there's no
kickstarter no indiegogo no actual
funding and there's no actual product
there's no physical prototype there's no
pre-order this is just an idea and foam
blocks is a campaign to spread this idea
through as many people as possible to
inspire the idea of a modular smartphone
being the smartphone of the future
essentially it's not a brand new or
revolutionary idea it's just the first
time this idea has been packaged into a
two-minute youtube video with sweet
animations and 3d graphics that everyone
can understand and i hope this does
really well i'm excited i love the idea
of a totally modular smartphone and
spreading this idea to as many people as
possible gives it hope and it's being
pretty successful right now at doing
exactly that so that is phone blocks
explained if you want to check out more
information about any of this stuff i've
talked about i'll have all the relevant
links right below that like button so
you can check them all out and i'll also
include my latest video about what i say
is the perfect smartphone i'll also
throw in a much older video i did
with my own video idea about a modular
smartphone so if you check that older
video out you'll probably see that the
ideas here are strikingly similar and
also have the youtube channel linked
below to the guy that did this so you
can check out all the other stuff he's
done and all the other projects that
weren't uh quite as successful as phone
blocks has been so far either way thank
you for watching this video if you want
to see more like this definitely
subscribe because there are a lot more
coming thanks for watching and i'll talk
to you guys in the next one peace
[Music]
you